[Music]
on this monday night another dose of
hope
a second potential kovid 19 vaccine
shows preliminary promise
i think we should approach this with
cautious optimism what we know
and don't know about the latest vaccine
candidate
overwhelmed and under pressure we
can't sustain this number of cases
hospital beds are filling up
right across canada plus keeping the
coronavirus under control
in classrooms could christmas break come
early
for some schools that's our last
solution
and finally allowed on the beach after
38 years
first time i've ever been on in my life
the island that's land mine free
and what it took to make it happen
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with what appears to be more
promising news about another vaccine
being developed to prevent covid19
the second in a week to exceed
expectations
moderna says preliminary data shows the
vaccine it is testing is 94.5 percent
effective
it requires two shots 28 days apart and
it does not need ultra cold storage
making it easier to distribute
pfizer's vaccine which showed 90
effectiveness in early results also
requires two doses but
it must be stored at minus 70 celsius
canada has pre-ordered tens of millions
of doses
from both moderna and pfizer this does
not mean that either of those vaccines
is approved for use the clinical trials
aren't complete and there is still much
more data to be analyzed
questions still remain including how
long either vaccine would protect you
but it is promising news as we head into
a dark winter
carolyn jarvis has our top story tonight
the moment we learned i ended up with a
grin from ear to ear
you know incredibly excited i put myself
on mute and yelled that excitement out
early results from moderna's covet 19
vaccine
exceeded even its own expectations at
94.5
percent effective a vaccine now in phase
three of clinical trials which involves
30 000 people but while moderna may be
celebrating
experts say we don't know enough just
yet i think we have to
really bring it back down to planet
earth for a second and see exactly what
they mean we don't actually have the
data this is really a press release
so you know at the surface it looks very
promising
but i think we should approach this with
cautious optimism the study isn't done
these are not the final results
modernist vaccine
like pfizers is using what's called an
mrna approach
it's a new type of vaccine that's never
been approved for use in people
mrna vaccines take the genetic code from
a virus
and use it to provoke an immune response
to answer the demand for its vaccine
moderna has set up
two manufacturing centers one based in
switzerland
for satisfying our commitments to canada
and one obviously in the united states
for satisfying the united states so they
do not
directly compete and we wouldn't expect
there to be any
waiting in line behind americans but
first comes approval
health canada is already reviewing data
from phase one and two of modernist
clinical trials
the full data set from phase three
should be submitted in the coming weeks
what we're really focusing on currently
is to make sure
that we analyze the data that come out
efficiently and we really want the
canadian population to know that we are
not cutting corners
if the data supports this vaccine it
will still be months before all
canadians receive it
in the meantime the health minister
cautions we have to remain vigilant
despite the fact that there's light at
the end of the tunnel we have dark
months ahead of us
and that if we want to protect our the
lives of the people that we love if we
want to protect our own wellness that we
can have to continue with the public
health measures carolyn jarvis global
news
toronto with case numbers surging canada
has crossed a grim
new milestone more than 300 000 cases
reported
since the start of this pandemic here's
the picture today in the atlantic bubble
there were 10
new cases eight of them in new brunswick
there were more than 1200 new cases
reported in quebec
more than 1400 in ontario alberta
reported 860 new cases today there were
almost 650
reported in bc and in manitoba the worst
per capita in canada there were nearly
400 new cases
and 10 more people died we
can't sustain this number of cases in
our health care system
our hospitals are near capacity we have
over 40 people in icu with covet 19
right now
our health care providers are becoming
overwhelmed
here's the path canada's hospitals are
on after a big drop in cases in the
summer the number of canadians ending up
in the hospital with covid19
is climbing as of november 7th there
were nearly 1400 covid19 patients in
hospital in canada
that is an increase of 16 from the
previous week
in ontario there are now so many
patients in some hard-hit regions
hospitals are warning
they are nearing capacity eric sorenson
reports on the growing strain
on the system and a campaign for
aggressive new restrictions
as of now trillium health partners three
hospitals in toronto and mississauga are
at 99 percent capacity
ontario has seen a spike in covid 19
cases and now hospitalizations are on
the rise too
from one month ago the number of cases
has almost doubled from over seven
hundred per day on a seven day average
to more than fourteen hundred cases per
day hospitalization stood at two hundred
thirty per day a month ago
now 459 per day this week at etobicoke
general they have 70 covid patients
but another 33 who are suspected and
need
separate rooms that are increasingly in
short supply
the 33 suspected cases need to be in 33
separate rooms
which makes it very difficult for us as
of now ontario has expanded its red zone
from toronto down to hamilton
with restrictions on restaurants and
gyms urging people to stop getting
together in groups
or going out at all except when
necessary i'm sorry for
a lot of the small businesses but it's
better to
have a healthy and safe community than
one that the virus just is totally out
of control
one specialist says ontario should bite
the bullet and impose a sweeping
lockdown a covid zero approach
because half measures he says aren't
working the problems with
color-coded systems is that they
encourage you
to tolerate low levels of disease which
inevitably get out of hand
so the only way to move forward is to
get control of covid19
ontario's chief medical officer is
considering lockdown measures but what
to lock down
businesses or schools or both and
hard-hit urban centers or the entire
province
what are the consequences of doing that
action at this time
are there severe consequences are they
minor consequences
but what's the benefits and to weigh
those out and to make sure you move on
them for the moment ontario's aim is to
improve the numbers before christmas
so families can get together but the
premier is also preparing ontarians for
a christmas without big family
gatherings
we'll always have other celebrations
we'll always have other christmases
but if the numbers continue to spike as
i said before i won't hesitate in a
heartbeat
to lock things down the numbers in
ontario are expected to keep rising
the question is how high will they have
to go for ontario to consider targeted
or widespread
lockdowns eric sorensen global news
toronto
rising numbers in alberta are straining
the system there were 20 new deaths
reported in that province today
and more than 860 new cases in 24 hours
the positivity rate is 7 percent now and
there are so many active cases contact
tracers can't keep up
alberta doctors have pleaded with
premier jason kenney to impose tougher
restrictions
but as heather urix west reports some
albertans are now
taking matters into their own hands four
weeks alberta's premier has
been clear protecting lives and
livelihoods is the reason why a lockdown
needs to be avoided at all costs
but at least one calgary business owner
says he is shutting down anyways
the owner of dickens pub shared this on
facebook sunday
we are going to close for two to three
weeks i care about my staff and my
customers
and it feels wrong to keep inviting
everybody down here with the case
numbers spiking badly
i feel like a tsunami siren is wailing
the head of calgary's emergency
management agency believes there is no
time to waste
calling on the province to shut down all
but essential businesses
for 28 days it's my job it's not popular
it's my job
to tell people when i think that we've
reached a tipping point
and that's where i feel we're at right
now but on sunday alberta's premier
continued to ask albertans to do the
right thing on their own
these are relatively modest measures and
i really hope that people respond
positively because if not
it's we'll have no option but to look at
more restrictive measures down the line
under alberta's public health act only
the provincial government has the
authority to implement a lockdown
public health officials can only offer
advice if you
publicly disagree with the government
you split
the leadership right at the very moment
that communities need
clear leadership dr james talbot was
alberta's chief medical officer of
health between
2012 and 2015. he says when there is a
disagreement with government it's often
best for public health officials
to continue working quietly behind the
scenes in the hopes of gaining
allies and changing minds but he also
warns that after a successful spring
and summer the situation in alberta has
become very
serious and without action icu's in the
province could be overrun
in just a few weeks time it's the last
period and there's a surge happening
and we have to clamp down on defense and
we have to play
every shift as if live spend it on
because they did
heather urex west global news calgary
none of it which reported its first case
10 days ago is ordering the closure of
non-essential businesses for two weeks
beginning on wednesday in the last 24
hours six new cases were confirmed in
irviat where a covet-19 outbreak has
been declared
and officials are concerned about
community transmission two new cases
have been reported in rankin
inlet bringing the territory's total
case count to 26.
under the mandatory restrictions schools
move to remote learning
child care centers are closed to all but
essential workers and non-essential
travel
is strongly discouraged in british
columbia there were nearly 2
000 new cases reported over the past
three days
we are in the most challenging of times
we have come through a wave we're now in
the midst
of our second this virus is in our
communities
and can spread very easily we need to
say no
to social gatherings right now we also
need to minimize our travel
we need to stay local stay in our
communities now
and take those measures which will help
us bend
our curve back down
how to stop the spread without
completely shutting down life is the
challenge everywhere
schools have mostly stayed open and
transmission of covid19 within schools
has been limited
but as the virus spreads through the
community that could change
some provinces are weighing whether to
start christmas break earlier
to reduce the risk robin gill explains
there have been five exposures at this
elementary school in surrey bc
since the new term began now it's
finally closed
because of an outbreak the most serious
kova 19 case involves a music teacher
who's in intensive care
parents wonder why the school wasn't
closed earlier she's the only music
teacher so for her to see
kindergarten all the way up to grade
four students in one
week that's that's breaking the cohorts
so why is it that
she is as a teacher is expected to see
that many students
two other schools in the province are
also closed there are staffing shortages
because teachers have had to
self-isolate
now there's talk of extending christmas
holidays to stop the spread
we're obviously looking at other
provinces that are considering
an extension of the holidays at the
other end following on
christmas and new year's activities bc
schools make up
less than 10 percent of the
approximately 13 000 cases that have
arisen since the start of the term
here's what it looks like in other parts
of the country in ontario more than 3
300
students and staff have been diagnosed
with coven 19.
it's three times that in quebec and that
province is considering an
earlier christmas break schools are a
place of transmission
that is why we're evaluating the
possibility
of closing the schools for a limited
period of time ontario is holding off
for now
that's the last resort to shut down
schools i
i know the parents enjoy that the kids
are going to school the kids enjoy it
but some infectious disease experts say
schools don't need to go back into
lockdown
absolutely not i think that would be the
last thing i would do
i continue to think of schools as
probably the safest environment that we
have
we know who goes in we know who comes
out
still that's not reassuring for all
parents it started in one class
that had to isolate it moved to two
other classes this school is just one
example of how the virus can move
swiftly
less than three months after returning
to the classrooms
robin gill global news surrey bc
pushed to the brink coming up the u.s
could see another million covet 19 cases
this week and doctors face having to
ration health care
plus the looming disaster from a
history-making hurricane
in the u.s worst case scenarios are
becoming real life
in some places with cases accelerating
fast and with no strategy from president
trump
mayors and governors are imposing new
restrictions but community spread is
already so rampant in some cities
hospitals are overwhelmed and doctors
are being forced to decide
who gets treatment and who does not
jackson proskow reports
in el paso texas the grim job of
transporting the dead has fallen to
prisoners
they load bodies into refrigerated
trailers there aren't enough health care
workers to do the job
in state after state hospitals are at or
near capacity
doctors may soon face tough choices
about who to treat
right now the trajectory of increase in
the number of cases per day
is astronomical it is extreme
the record number of hospitalizations
today is the result of infections from
two weeks ago two weeks from now the
situation could be apocalyptic
we do know what's coming we're seeing so
many cases
day over day that unless definitive
steps are taken to interrupt the
transmission cycle
exceeding capacity is a mathematical
inevitability
restrictions are coming back fast
chicago has moved to a stay-at-home
advisory
most of california faces sharp
restrictions michigan has told high
school and college students to stay home
if we don't take aggressive action right
now
we could soon see 1 000
deaths per week here in michigan
president trump's top coronavirus
adviser
slammed the shutdowns tweeting the only
way this stops is if people rise up
while trump has effectively given up on
efforts to control the virus
if we have to wait until january 20th to
start that planning
it puts us behind over a month month and
a half for now
president-elect joe biden is helpless to
do anything about it
having been blocked from starting a
formal transition of power
by trump's refusal to concede by the
time
biden is inaugurated in late january
models suggest
more than 360 000 americans will have
died
the arrival of a vaccine will not erase
the staggering tall of the pandemic
growing worse with every day jackson
prosko
global news washington
still ahead the peculiar parrot that won
a battle of the birds
you're watching global national
[Music]
another fierce hurricane is bearing down
on an already battered central america
hurricane iota is now a category five
the strongest of the season
it rapidly gained strength in the past
48 hours and with 260 kilometer an hour
winds
damage could be catastrophic iota is
forecast to make landfall in northern
nicaragua tonight
the region is still recovering from
hurricane atta that storm brought
intense rain that triggered floods and
landslides in three countries
and killed up to 150 people iota is the
30th named storm to form in the atlantic
this year that is unprecedented
the last time there was a category five
storm this late in the season
was 1932. in new zealand a winner has
emerged in a cutthroat
bird of the year competition
can't fly and it hides during the day
but the
cacopa has been declared new zealand's
bird of the year it's the world's
heaviest parrot and it's the longest
living those traits make it vulnerable
that kakopa was on the brink of
extinction in the 1990s
thanks to conservation efforts there are
now 213 of them
and just fyi they apparently smell like
the inside of a well-used clarinet case
and there are allegations of voter fraud
in this uh
contest the polyamorous he he was
endorsed by an
adult toy store yes and the little
spotted kiwi received 1500 votes cast
one night from the same
ip address even avian democracy is under
threat
it seems up next 38 years after war the
falkland islands are finally free
of land mines
every day somewhere in the world someone
dies or loses a limb because they
stepped on a land mine
the weapons of war are left behind to
kill and maim civilians long
after conflicts have ended in the case
of the falkland islands it's been almost
40 years now people there can finally
safely walk on the beaches again thanks
in part to a treaty signed
here in canada crystal commencing
reports
digging in the sand and playing this
beach and all of the falkland islands
are now land mine free
yeah it's brilliant this is the first
time i've ever been on it in my life
for nearly 40 years land mines littered
this region
a tactical and deadly weapon used by
argentina during the falklands war with
britain
in 1982 in 2009
clearing efforts began gamora was there
on day one
and was on the beach when the last one
was detonated in a special ceremony
it was a very emotional day for people
here it was certainly
i found it really quite emotional by the
time i got to the end of my speech on
the day
trying to control the lower lip more
than 12 000
anti-personnel minds were physically
collected
this little anti-personnel mine is the
most common mine in the falklands
britain was obligated to clear the mines
from its land under the ottawa treaty
more than 160 countries have signed the
treaty
agreeing to ban the use production and
sale of landmines
lloyd axworthy helped launch the ottawa
treaty process
and says more work is still needed the
bad news is that
some of it's coming back and they're
still being used in some very
crucial conflict areas around the world
according to the international campaign
to ban
landmines more than 60 countries and
regions around the world are
contaminated by landmines
with thousands of people living with the
deadly threat every day
princess diana famously drew attention
to the plight by walking in a minefield
in angola in 1997 and her son
sent a message to the people of
falklands
you are taking another step towards
defining yourselves
as the modern community spirited place
that you have built
a spirited and now safe place for future
generations
crystal gamansen global news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is winnipeg we'd
love to see your canada please send it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye